pour ce débat j'accueille Nathalie
Loiseau bonsoir vous êtes heureux député
membre du parti horizon d'Edouard
Philippe soutient d'Emmanuel Macron
Hervé juin bonsoir député européen
membre du rassemblement national et
soutien de Marine Le Pen Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés vous allez débattre dans un
instant de la vision de l'Europe de vos
candidats et candidates respectifs et
respectives mais d'abord l'OTAN vient de
voir sur ce reportage et cette
déclaration de Marine Le Pen lors de sa
conférence de presse sur la politique
internationale si elle devient
présidente la France quittera le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN on
l'écoute
je ne le placerai simplement jamais nos
forces armées sous un commandement qui
ne relève pas de la souveraineté
nationale française ni sous un
commandement intégré de l'OTAN ni sous
un futur commandement européen
la France est un État fondateur de
l'OTAN et c'est à l'OTAN non à l'Union
européenne que nous devons une paire
relative sur le continent européen si
l'on exclut les conditions de la
dislocation de la Yougoslavie
je ne proposerai donc pas de quitter le
temps mais son commandement intégrés
comme ce fut le cas de 1966 à 2009
Hervé est-ce que ça veut dire que la
France dépensera moins aussi pour l'OTAN
à certainement pas pour sa défense je
crois que les propos de Marine Le Pen
sont claires d'abord évidemment nous
restons dans le Traité de l'Atlantique
Nord la question est qu'on assiste
depuis quelques années quelques mois
tout particulièrement à une dérive de
l'OTAN j'ai connu le temps au sein de
l'OTAN les forces qui participaient au
commandement intégré devait avoir des
matériels militaires compatibles on voit
bien qu'on a évolué vers une situation
où
appartenir à l'OTAN et rester dans le
commandement militaire intégré CHT
américain l'OTAN devient une dépendance
le temps devient un marché du complexe
militaro industriel américain je ne peux
que regretter à cet égard le choix
récent de l'Allemagne d'acheter les F-35
plutôt que le Rafale d'autres pays
européens de négliger l'offre française
de défense dont je rappelle que c'est de
très loin la plus importante en Europe
que nous avons une défense indépendante
notamment par rapport au choix du
nucléaire fait en son temps par le
général de Gaulle et je finirai en
disant que Marine Le Pen ne fait que
répéter les propos du général de Gaulle
s'il y a une guerre il faut que ce soit
sa guerre il faut que ce soit la guerre
de la France et nous n'avons pas nous
laisser entraîner dans des conflits qui
ne sont pas les nôtres par des
puissances qui ne cherchent pas
nécessairement notre intérêt national
Nathalie Loiseau quelles conséquence
pourrait avoir une telle décision sortir
du commandement intégré de l'OTAN c'est
d'avoir moins son mot à dire dans une
alliance à laquelle on participe c'est
quand même étrange de dire nous voulons
bien faire partie du club mais surtout
ne pas participer au cœur de la
discussion nous avons besoin parce que
nous sommes une grande puissance
militaire d'être entendue nous avons
besoin que le pilier européen de l'OTAN
soit à la fois plus crédible et
davantage capable de mettre en avant ces
priorités qui sont les nôtres et pas
toujours celle des États-Unis c'est donc
essentiel d'être non seulement dans le
temps mais d'être dans le commandement
intégré de l'OTAN ce qui ne veut pas
dire que l'on se trouve entraîné malgré
soi dans quelque chose que l'on ne
souhaite pas d'abord parce que dans le
temps tout est décisions sont prises par
consensus c'est un membre n'est pas
d'accord il n'y a pas de décision et
ensuite parce que l'emploi des forces
armées est toujours du ressort du chef
de l'État ou du chef de gouvernement
chef des armées donc la solidarité
demandée par l'OTAN à l'ensemble de ces
membres est une solidarité donc chaque
État peut décider la forme qu'elle prend
ça nous amène évidemment au premier
chapitre de notre débat autour de
l'Europe sur la défense européenne vous
l'avez évoqué
Nathalie Loiseau c'était l'un des
combats d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
c'est l'un des échecs de son quinquennat
de ne pas avoir réussi sur ce plan ah je
crois que c'est tout à fait le contraire
je me souviens de 2017 le discours de la
Sorbonne ou entre autres le président
Macron mettait en avant l'autonomie
stratégique de l'Union européenne
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé cette année
pour la première fois l'Union européenne
adopte sa revue stratégique son livre
blanc c'est-à-dire qu'elle se met
d'accord sur la nature des menaces
qu'elle doit affronter et sur la manière
d'y répondre l'autonomie stratégique est
mentionnée dans ce livre blanc à
plusieurs reprises comme quelque chose
de naturel qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que nous travaillons avec nos
alliés chaque fois que nous le pouvons
mais de manière autonome chaque fois que
nous le devons et nous savons bien qu'il
y a des enjeux sur lesquels l'OTAN n'est
pas la bonne réponse quand la Grèce se
sent menacé par l'attitude de la Turquie
ça n'est évidemment pas au sein de
l'OTAN que ça pourra
nous avons besoin de l'Union européenne
d'ailleurs la Grèce a fait l'acquisition
de d'avions français de Rafale lorsque
nous sommes engagés au sel et nous
continuerons à l'être en dépit des
dérives de la gente malienne qui nous
conduit à nous retirer du Mali mais il
reste d'autres pays avec lesquels nous
allons continuer à lutter contre un
terrorisme qui nous menace nous aussi
est-ce que c'est le temps qui s'en est
chargé jusqu'à présent pas du tout c'est
à l'Union européenne et aussi à des
formations Haddock à des formats à
quelques-uns de traiter ce type de sujet
Hervé juin que propose Marine Le Pen en
matière de défense une défense nationale
indépendante ça suppose quoi qu'elle
dépense quel budget
Marine Le Pen a évoqué un budget de la
défense en hausse significative Marine
Le Pen a évoqué et vous l'avez dit et
confirmé le souhait d'indépendance de la
France mais je voudrais revenir sur les
propos de Nathalie Loiseau je
souhaiterais comme vous que la France
puisse être entendue au sein du corps
humain intégré de l'OTAN je souhaiterais
comme vous qu'il y ait réellement
discussion à parité entre allier ce que
je constate et que je déplore depuis
trop d'années c'est que nous alliés
américains il n'est pas question pour
moi de sortir de cette alliance nous
considère beaucoup moins comme des
alliés à égalité que tombe des
supplétifs on le voit notamment dans
cette affaire dans l'invasion
de la Russie en Ukraine ou très
clairement ce sont les États-Unis qui
sont à la manœuvre très clairement ce
sont les États-Unis qui décident des
affectations d'armes des déploiements
divers et où très clairement l'idée d'un
commandement intégré où nous aurions
notre parole et notre voie à exprimer se
réduit à peu près rien mais faites-vous
partie
était un échec et vous le savez bien les
pays européens n'ont pas nous avons été
seul à porter l'effort de défense et
d'ailleurs le Haut représentant Josep
Borel a bien dit que le Mali estacuba
c'était une initiative française et
qu'il ne s'en sortait pas responsable
bon un mot de réponse là-dessus alors
takuba se sont 10 États membres de
l'Union européenne 10 des pays pour qui
le Sahel n'était pas spontanément
combien de soldats le plus immédiat moi
j'ai le plus profond respect pour les
Forces Spéciales check pour les Suédois
pour les Estoniens qui nous ont conjoint
au Sahel et je ne voudrais pas les
regarder avec une sorte de mépris comme
si il n'avait rien fait là où ils
étaient ils sont extraordinairement
puissants pourquoi est-ce que
aujourd'hui nous avons des difficultés
au Mali parce que la Russie avec
laquelle Marine Le Pen souhaite passer
une alliance
à souhaiter soutenir une jante
issue de deux coups d'états successifs
au Mali a envoyé des mercenaires du
groupe Wagner qui sont connus pour les
exactions en matière de droits de
l'homme j'ai profondément regretté que
les députés européens du rassemblement
national lorsque nous avons dénoncé ces
exactions épouvantables du groupe Wagner
en Afrique notamment et voter contre
cette dénonciation n'est pas considéré
peut-être pour ne pas contrarier
Vladimir Poutine qu'il y avait là un
sujet ce sujet est majeur et revenons à
l'Ukraine qui est à la manœuvre en
Ukraine Vladimir Poutine la liée de
Madame Le Pen qui est à l'origine de
crime de guerre en Ukraine Vladimir
Poutine et ses troupes j'étais il y a
quelques jours à bout de chat allez-y je
regrette que aucun député ni européen ni
national de l'extrême droite ne se soit
rendue acief et à bout de chat pour voir
de ses propres yeux pour entendre les
témoignages des familles des hommes qui
ont été exécutés des femmes et des
enfants qui ont été violé à mort sur
ordre de militaires de Vladimir Poutine
je vous entends pour ma part j'étais à
la frontière entre la Hongrie et
l'Ukraine pour voir l'accueil réservé
par les Hongrois au réfugiés je ne peux
que déplorer d'ailleurs les sanctions
dont la Hongrie ou la Pologne qui
accueille vous le savez des millions de
réfugiés font en ce moment l'objet mais
nous nous éloignons nous éloignons un
peu du sujet je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire que Vladimir Poutine et la liée de
Marine Le Pen nous avons voté les
sanctions contre la Russie je viens de
m'exprimer il y a quelques heures sur le
fait que nous devons nous passer du gaz
russe et nous devons appliquer les
sanctions est-ce que vous avez est-ce
que vous l'avez voté pardonnez-moi mais
la semaine dernière en plénière les
députés du rassemblement national n'ont
pas pris part au vote tout simplement
parce que nous étions dans le dernier
meeting de la campagne présidentielle à
Perpignan tous indispensables c'est très
curieux parce que je crois que nous
faisons nous aussi une campagne
présidentielle et nous étions présents
il y a un moment où moi-même je ne
l'étais pas parce que que j'étais en
Ukraine précisément pour juger moi-même
pour voir de mes propres yeux donc il
faut rappeler qu'effectivement le
Parlement européen a une très large
majorité à voter pour des sanctions
beaucoup plus lourdes contre la Russie
embargo contre sur le pétrole et le gaz
russe effectivement les euros députés du
rassemblement national n'était pas
présent nous avions voté le premier
train sanction et comme je vous l'ai dit
nous étions tous à Perpignan parce qu'il
est le meeting avait lieu ce soir à la
même c'est curieux que tous les autres
et nous ne sommes pas opposés qui
étaient tous présents
dans la campagne présidentielle et
trouver
utile permettez-moi de revenir en
arrière je ne peux pas vous laisser dire
que vous êtes un allié tout simplement
parce que nous sommes attachés à la
souveraineté des peuples et des nations
et j'ai eu plusieurs reprises d'occasion
de le dire je me félicite de la
naissance du sentiment national
ukrainien ce qui est en train de se
passer manifestement et ce qui
probablement provoque les difficultés
auxquelles les troupes russes qui ne s'y
attendait pas rencontre sur le terrain
c'est qu'on a bien eu la naissance d'une
nation et nous ne pouvons que nous en
féliciter nous sommes fiers et nous
sommes heureux de soutenir est-ce que
vous la divers outils de faire
disparaître cette nation est-ce que
c'est un génocide comme l'a dit Joe
Biden et j'ai entendu le président
Emmanuel Macron dire que naturellement
des crimes de guerre valaient une
enquête internationale indépendante que
naturellement nous souhaitons et nous
soutenons je pense que sur ces sujets là
il y a un sujet d'unité nationale et de
défense de la place de la France dans le
monde je ne saurais qu'à prouver les
propositions du président Emmanuel
Macron et j'ai aussi observé que le
président Emmanuel Macron n'adoptait en
rien les accusations de génocide de Joe
Biden il n'a pas repris ce terme il fait
je souligne d'ailleurs comme l'avait dit
Emmanuel Macron que ça ne sert à rien de
traiter vladim routine de fou criminels
ne prenez pas ce que je vais dire pour
une défense de Vladimir Poutine si vous
me permettez une minute je relisais le
texte de Bob Kennedy sur la position de
John Fitzgerald Kennedy au moment de la
crise de Cuba John Fitzgerald Kennedy
dit ça n'est pas supportable que la
Russie pose des missiles nucléaires à
quelques centaines de kilomètres des
côtes américaines mais attention il ne
s'agit pas d'humilier ce grand pays qui
est la Russie et donc il a demandé aux
militaires de faire extrêmement
attention à ce que toutes leurs actions
soient prévisibles et ensuite une fois
que la Russie de Khrouchtchev l'Union
soviétique a retiré les missiles John
Fitzgerald Kennedy a donné l'ordre de ne
jamais parler de victoire et de ne
jamais humilier la Russie je pense que
c'est un véritable thème je pense que
c'est le thème du retour de la
diplomatie j'ai vu que monsieur disait
qu'il était passé
si vous voulez mais
surprise que vous ne vouliez pas assumer
ce qui est dans le programme de Madame
Le Pen
veut pas dire l'alliance avec la Russie
elle l'a écrit noir sur blanc elle l'a
redit à plusieurs reprises c'est un
fondamental de la position du Front
national d'abord du rassemblement
national ensuite je ne vous ferai pas la
liste fastidieuse des voyages de Madame
Le Pen en Russie pour rencontrer ou bien
Vladimir Poutine ou bien ses proches une
fois ou bien ses proches elles s’est
rendue à plusieurs reprises en 2013 en
2014 en 2017 Thierry Mariani on ne
compte plus ses voyages en Russie plus
de 50 Madame Le Pen a considéré que la
Crimée était russe et que ça ne posait
pas de difficultés le rassemblement
national a envoyé en Russie des
observateurs électoraux et je mets des
guillemets pour
crédibiliser des scrutins que tout la
communauté internationale a considéré
comme n'ét crédible c'est le choix de
Madame Le Pen d'être proche de Vladimir
Poutine elle a dit qu'elle partageait sa
vision elle a exprimé son admiration
c'est un choix qu'il faut assumer il ne
faut pas aujourd'hui mettre un foyer et
faire croire vous avez la peine de se
faire déjà exposé vos arguments sur la
question Vladimir Poutine on va
maintenant ouvrir vraiment le dossier de
la comparaison des programmes des deux
finalistes sur
l'Europe et d'abord avec ce sujet ce
comparatif signé Gaspard flamand
pour Marine Le Pen plus question
d'abandonner l'euro et de quitter
l'Union européenne le projet du
rassemblement national n'en reste pas
moins heureux-sceptique si la candidate
est élue elle compte baisser la
contribution de la France au budget
européen de 5 milliards d'euros elle
veut aussi rétablir les contrôles
permanents aux frontières et refusent
l'idée d'une Europe de la défense enfin
Marine Le Pen rejoint également la
Hongrie et la Pologne sur les questions
de souveraineté nationale
nous avons de la nécessaire
transformation de l'Union européenne en
alliance européenne des nations
probablement une vision commune de la
même manière que nous avons une vision
commune sur la nécessité de la primauté
de la constitution des nations
souveraines sur les directives ou
traités de quelques natures que ce soit
hier Emmanuel Macron avait lui choisi
Strasbourg pour son premier meeting
d'entre eux de Tours ville symbole de
l'union européenne le président candidat
s'affiche comme en 2017 en neurofiles
convaincu et plaide pour une Europe plus
unie plus forte pour cela plusieurs axes
Emmanuel Macron souhaite réformer
l'espace Schengen pour lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine il veut aussi
une Europe de la défense avec un
renforcement des capacités des armées
européennes et une autonomie énergétique
le projet européen qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui nous devons le défendre
comme des militants de l'espérance comme
des militants de l'humanisme comme des
militants de l'avenir
il n'hésite pas non plus à taper sur son
adversaire du second tour et donc oui le
projet de l'extrême droite c'est un
projet de sortie du Conseil de l'Europe
c'est à dire de notre socle de valeurs
et de droit sortir du Conseil de
l'Europe c'est sortir de l'Union
européenne puisqu'elle en est la
Constitution le principe fondateur des
questions au cœur de l'actualité puisque
le candidat qui l'emportera le 24 avril
prendra en charge la présidence
française de l'Union européenne jusqu'au
mois de juin
et dans ces bases accueille notre expert
tanière à Chaumont soir bienvenue vous
êtes docteur en droit européen
chercheuse associée à l'Institut
d'études de droits publics de
Paris-Saclay et membre du collectif Les
surligneurs notre partenaire dans cette
présidentielle pour passer au crible les
propositions des candidats sous l'angle
juridique et vous publiez voilà
plusieurs
ouvrages notamment celui-ci politique
immigration et réfugiés il y a aussi
politique religion et là et cité et si
on ressortait toutes ces promesses
intenables de nos politiques voilà le
sous-titre de ces de ces livres alors je
vous propose sur l'Europe une
déclaration pour lancer ce débat elle
est signée Emmanuel Macron il met en
garde sur le programme de Marine Le Pen
écoutez et donc avec la plus grande
force vous me verrez m'opposer à ce
projet parce que c'est le retour du
nationalisme et le retour de la guerre
jamais
Nathalie l'oiseau votre candidat il
accuse Marine Le Pen de carabistouille
sur leur pourquoi j'ai le sentiment que
le programme de Madame Le Pen ne change
pas beaucoup sur le fond mais qui change
d'emballage à chaque fois vous avez
rappelé 2017 2019 alors le frexit pas le
frexit l'euro pas l'euro on sait tous un
peu perdu j'ai essayé de comprendre en
l'écoutant tout à l'heure dans sa
conférence de presse ce qu'elle
proposait aujourd'hui elle dit je ne
veux pas sortir de l'Union européenne
parce qu'elle sait tout simplement que
c'est terriblement impopulaire mais
immédiatement après elle explique que
elle ne paiera pas la part de la France
au budget de l'Union européenne
c'est une drôle de manière de rester
dans l'Union elle explique que le droit
européen ne peut pas être supérieur aux
droits français c'est une autre drôle de
manière de rester dans l'Union et c'est
de ne pas le rassemblement national
qu'elle devrait avoir comme nom pour son
parti c'est l'isolement national parce
que
elle n'aurait personne personne au sein
de l'Union européenne pour la suivre au
niveau des chefs d'État et gouvernement
et au Parlement européen je peine à
trouver je n'ai jamais trouvé quelque
chose que les députés européens du
rassemblement national on fait pour
changer l'Union européenne moi je ne
suis pas une admiratrice béate d'une
Union européenne qui devrait ne pas
changer simplement depuis que je suis au
Parlement européen nous avons essayé de
bouger les lignes si nous en étions
restés à l'Europe de Madame Le Pen nous
n'aurions jamais eu de commandes
groupées de vaccins qui ont permis de
vacciner tous les Européens et
gratuitement s'agissant de nous tous
nous n'aurions jamais eu un plan de
relance qui a permis de sauver les
entreprises qui a permis de créer des
emplois qui nous permet de transformer
nos économies de les rendre plus
numérique plus vertes rien de tout cela
n'aurait été possible alors que Madame
Le Pen plus dire frexit ça la regarde
mais ça ne trompe personne elle continue
d'ailleurs à dire à qui veut l'entendre
que le brexit est une réussite alors que
le Royaume-Uni de Boris Johnson souffre
jour après jour des conséquences de
cette décision hasardeuse qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il y a plus d'inflation
il y a moins de main d'oeuvre il y a
moins de d'exportation britannique que
partout dans l'Union européenne alors
décision air de ça a été un vote
populaire
quand même il faut le redire est-ce
qu'il y a un frexit caché une sortie
cachée absolument pas de toute manière
d'ailleurs vous l'avez souligné Nathalie
Loiseau l'Union européenne doit devoir
évoluer elle va devoir évoluer sur un
certain nombre de sujets fondamentaux
sur lequel pour ma part modestement j'ai
essayé de faire des propositions il est
évident que la nécessité urgente de
financer l'effort de défense et
d'armement de l'Europe ne peut pas
s'accommoder de la taxonomie telle
qu'elle a été définie nous devons savoir
financer nos industries de défense la
taxonomie c'est cette machine
bureaucratique qui soumet tout
financement d'entreprises à son score
soi-disant vert environnemental et qui
tendait à exclure les financements de
l'armement
[Musique]
vous savez que ça a été une bataille
compliquée pour que nous gagnons que
vous avez gagné que nous avons gagné
ensemble pour que le nucléaire ne soit
pas exclu sur beaucoup de sujets je
pense à fit for fifty-five le projet
soi-disant environnemental qui équivaut
la consommation d'énergie au dégagement
de CO2 alors qu'il y a des énergies non
carbonées notamment le nucléaire je
pense à la stratégie ferme tout fort
qu'il va falloir corriger parce que nous
allons nous trouver face à des pénuries
alimentaires sur beaucoup de sujets
l'Union européenne doivent devoir
corriger sa route donc je ne sais pas
dire que nous préparons un frexit nous
pensons de l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne que l'on peut corriger les
choses avec moi nous ne manquons pas
d'allier avec notamment ce projet de
révision de la Constitution on y viendra
aux Alliés révision de la Constitution
par référendum en y intégrant la
préférence nationale la primauté du
droit français tanière à chaux la
Pologne a également voulu donner la
primauté à son bras national sur le
droit européen avec quelles conséquence
alors oui effectivement cette réforme
est même précisée en dans le programme
puisque le projet de loi constitutionnel
est indiqué d'ailleurs un peu à l'image
ce qui avait fait Valérie Pécresse et
l'exemple polonais et allemand sont
mentionnés dans le programme alors pas
son conséquence puisque alors il faut
revenir un petit peu en arrière mais le
tribunal consuel polonais en octobre
2021 avait décidé que deux articles du
traité de l'Union européenne n'était pas
conforme à la Constitution polonaise
donc effectivement il y avait une
question de problématique de primauté si
la Constitution polonaise l'emporte ça
pose ça interroge sur l'application du
droit Robert par la suite et assez
rapidement d'ailleurs la Commission
européenne a engagé ce qui s'appelle une
procédure en manquement c'est-à-dire de
violation du droit européen et en
l'occurrence donc du principe de
primauté donc à l'heure actuelle c'est
une procédure en cours parce que ça
prend un petit peu de temps il y a une
discussion qui a installée avec la
Pologne mais il y a plusieurs procédures
avec la Pologne et il y a notamment des
questions liées à l'indépendance des
juges polonais et par exemple en sur la
question de cette indépendance des juges
polonais et bien la Cour de Justice a
décidé que tant que une chambre
disciplinaire de la Cour suprême
polonaise n'était pas suspendue la
Pologne devrait payer un million d'euros
par jour d'astreinte et donc en février
je crois qu'elle en était à 69 millions
qu'elle devait régler avec des questions
de ponctionner directement sur le budget
polonais en l'absence de règlement et ça
c'est fini de façon plutôt positive
disons parce que il y a eu des
propositions polonaises de modification
du système c'est en cours évidemment
mais ça démontre bien que à la fin la
Pologne est obligé de se plier aux
exigences européennes et sur la primauté
si je peux juste continuer sur la
question de la modification de la
Constitution ce qui est intéressant
c'est que
dans le projet maintenant ce qui est
précisé c'est que le droit que la
Constitution doit imprimer sur le droit
européen alors que avant ce qui était
plutôt prévu c'était que le toutes les
lois nationales devaient primer sur le
droit européen et c'est pas du tout la
même chose de façon très pragmatique
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt le cas déjà en
fait c'est quelque chose qui est déjà en
place il y a déjà des mécanismes
français en cours pour faire en sorte
que la Constitution l'identité constitue
elle française puisse exister malgré le
droit européen enfin c'est pas ça veut
dire que Marine Le Pen a demandé son son
programme pour prendre moins de risques
de sanctions européennes si je comprends
bien probablement vous assumez quand
même le risque de sanctions sur sur
cette révision constitutionnelle la
primauté du droit national sur le droit
et ce sujet j'ai eu l'occasion récemment
d'organiser un débat à Cracovie sur ce
thème avec des Polonais avec des
Allemands avec différents pays leur
réflexion est que
solliciter les textes conduit à beaucoup
de choses vous devez savoir très bien le
faire le sentiment de nos amis polonais
qui nous ont expliqué en détail comment
les procédures de nomination et de
validation des juges allemands étaient
très peu différents
la France ça n'est pas un état balte
sans aucun mépris pour les États qui
réellement et récemment rejoint l'Union
la France est un État fondateur de
l'Union si la France dit que des choses
doivent changer au sein de l'Union nous
n'avons pas de doute des choses
changeront le poids institutionnel le
poids économique le poids de d'État
fondateur de la France est-elle que nous
n'avons pas à nous résigner dans les
propos d'Emmanuel Macron j'entendais
beaucoup il faut accepter l'Union telle
qu'elle nous conduit était lequel nous
le dirige mais enfin nous n'avons pas
nous soumettre je souhaiterais
d'ailleurs qu'Emmanuel Macron candidat
est un rendez-vous avec Emmanuel Macron
président parce que qu'a-t-il fait pour
changer Schengen qu'a-t-il fait pour
agir sur l'immigration ce que propose
Emmanuel Macron en disant que tout
atteinte à ce qui nous vient de l'Union
européenne et de la Commission
européenne conduirait la France à sortir
de l'Union et c'est un peu ce que vous
avez repris mais en fait quel soumission
quelle dépossession des Français les
Français ont envie de reprendre le
contrôle de à l'heure arrive ça veut
dire que autant l'Union européenne est
totalement légitime à décider d'un
certain nombre de choses autant nous
devons répondre à la main ça s'appelait
la subsidiarité c'est un mécanisme qui
était au cœur du processus européen dans
les années 90 nous devons renouer tout
simplement mais la réponse de Nathalie
Loiseau mais l'Union européenne monsieur
Juvin c'est nous ça n'est pas la
commission la commission elle a un
pouvoir d'initiative mais au total qui
décide dans l'Union européenne ce sont
les ministres ou leur chef d'État et
gouvernement d'un côté de l'autre ce
sont les députés européens élus au
suffrage universel donc moi je ne sens
pas de dépossession lorsque l'Union
européenne décide c'est nous qui
décidons sur la base du mandat que nous
ont donné nos électeurs je comprends
bien que pour vous c'est compliqué parce
que vous avez toujours et vous êtes
toujours isolé personne ne suit vos
recommandations et d'ailleurs lorsque
l'Union européenne avance et largement
et notamment depuis l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron sous son impulsion dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme par exemple vous
votez contre donc il y a un discours à
Paris et puis il y a une réalité à
Strasbourg et à Bruxelles c'est que vous
êtes systématiquement contre et vous
êtes systématiquement isolé heureusement
que ça n'est pas votre ligne qui a
prévalu parce que quand il s'agit par
exemple de créer et de renforcer
l'Agence européenne de garde frontières
un vrai sujet pour lutter contre
l'immigration illégale mais aussi contre
la criminalité
transfrontalière vous étiez contre au
rassemblement national
des migrants
le travail de Fontaine nous sommes allés
dans les îles grecques écoutez moi je
suis allé à Varsovie où est le siège de
Frontex j'ai vu ce qu'ils font en ce
moment en Moldavie en Roumanie partout
ou arrive les réfugiés
Ukrainiens ils aident à l'accueil et
c'est une très bonne chose ils aident
aussi à lutter contre les trafiquants
qui pourraient essayer de profiter de
cette large ouverture des frontières
vous vous étiez contre le fait qu'il y
ait des garde-fontières et des
garde-côtes européens pour aider des
pays à dans des moments de crise où il
devient très difficile de faire face
tout seul alors on va parler des
alliances c'est l'un des thèmes
importants de ce débat et je propose à
Quentin calmer de devenir sur ce plateau
on le voit quand un revançoire depuis le
début de ce débat qui est très
intéressant de vision aux antipodes et
ça se ressent aussi dans les alliances
qui sont noués au Parlement européen
exactement à l'élection présidentielle
sera pour les Français l'occasion de
trancher entre deux visions de l'Europe
c'est ce qui avait dit Marine Le Pen en
janvier dernier la candidate du qui
prône une Europe des nations elle essaie
depuis les élections européennes de 2019
de former un contre modèle à
l'organisation actuelle notamment avec
d'autres souverainistes en Europe les
tentatives qui se sont jusqu'aujourd'hui
un soldés pas des échecs alors avec le
renouvellement des le renouvellement des
instances en janvier dernier à mi-manda
au Parlement européen Marine Le Pen a
essayé de créer avec 14 autres parties
souverainistes d'extrême droite et
conservateurs une nouvelle alliance au
sein des instances européennes nombre de
leurs représentants étaient réunis à
Varsovie en décembre dernier d'ailleurs
on va vous montrer quelques images
autour de la table il y avait le Premier
ministre et patron du fidèle ce hongrois
à Victor urban ou encore le chef du
parti droit et justice en Pologne le pis
et le président du parti Vox en Espagne
ou encore la chef de Fratelli Italia
avait été également invité l'idée était
de créer une alliance qui serait la
deuxième ou troisième force au Parlement
européen parmi les sujets qui les
rapprochaient ils l'arrêt des flux
migratoires ou encore la souveraineté on
y revient un des pays au-dessus de celle
du droit européen écoutez alors Marine
Le Pen nous sommes le 3 décembre dernier
elle se dit optimiste sur la création
d'une telle alliance que les Hongrie je
suis aujourd'hui en Pologne et parce que
je considère que c'est important mais
c'est important également quand je serai
élu président de la République si les
Français me font confiance parce que il
faut avoir des alliés il faut parler
avec des dirigeants il faut avoir des
visions communes il faut porter des des
combats qui sont des combats communs et
en l'espèce cette force politique que
nous travaillons à constituer peut-être
une grande puissance puisque ce grand
groupe européen si un jour il voit le
jour et quand il verra le jour sera la
deuxième force au sein du Parlement
européen alors finalement ce groupe n'a
pas réussi à s'organiser en groupe uni
la réunion de Varsovie n'a donné que ce
cette somme déclaration commune la photo
piste le parti droit la justice polonais
très peu compatible avec Corban et Le
Pen sur la relation à entretenir avec la
Russie on y revient dont il se méfie
énormément la guerre en Ukraine Thomas a
achevé la rupture au sein de cette
possible à Lyon merci Quentin hervé
Juvin pas facile de nouer des alliances
au Parlement européen ça ça promet
ça n'empêche pas que sur beaucoup de
sujets nous travaillons ensemble il se
trouve que je suis presque
quotidiennement en contact avec des
députés polonais avec des députés
hongrois avec aussi des députés d'autres
parties d'ailleurs on a évoqué l'Espagne
évidemment l'Italie nous apprenons à
travailler ensemble vous avez tout à
fait raison ça ne se fait pas tout seul
vous avez tout à fait raison des
alliances ça veut dire aussi qu'on sache
dépasser des points de désaccord et il
est clair que sur la question des
relations avec la Russie la Hongrie et
la Pologne ont des positions différentes
et vous de la même manière que la bulle
verrerie
nous avons condamné sans ambage
l'invasion de la Russie nous sommes
attachés à la souveraineté de l'Ukraine
donc il est très clair et ça a été
manifesté récemment il est très clair
que nous nous sentons proches de la
Pologne sur ce sujet d'accord
financer quand même par une banque
hongroise dans cette campagne
donc hongroise qui est tenu par des amis
de Victor urban là vous posez la
question du peu de démocratie en France
vous posez la question de
l'impossibilité pour un parti comme le
rassemblement national qui représente je
le souhaite plus de 50% des électeurs
français d'être financés par un
établissement bancaire ou financier
français et ça ça pose quelques
questions ça pose quelques questions sur
l'ampleur de la corruption ça pose
quelques questions encore le mur de
l'argent si vous tenez une telle un tel
propos c'est quelle accusation
sur le mur de l'argent est-ce que on
peut trouver
normal dans une démocratie qu'un parti
qui représente soyons modeste le tiers
des électeurs ne puisse pas trouver de
financement de campagne Emmanuel Macron
s'était engagé et ça me semblait une
promesse utile à créer une banque de la
démocratie ça n'a pas été fait ça
s'appelle un étouffement de la
démocratie
corrompt dans cette affaire bref sur les
alliances
écoutez est-ce que la France serait
affaiblie j'imagine que vous allez me
répondre oui si Marine Le Pen était du
président de la République au niveau
européen
ce sont les Européens qui m'appellent ou
qui m'écrivent 30 fois par jour de tous
les pays de l'Union européenne et qui
expriment leur inquiétude pour la France
et pour le projet européen dans son
ensemble qui disent qu'est-ce que l'on
peut faire pour éviter une catastrophe
pareil c'est à dire que un pays
fondateur de l'Union européenne se
retrouverait en déclin en repli avec le
choix d'une alliance avec Vladimir
Poutine ne venait pas monsieur Juvin
dire que vous êtes proche du pis
polonais aujourd'hui le premier ministre
polonais a clairement déclaré qu'il ne
voulait plus faire alliance avec Victor
urban celui grâce à qui Madame Le Pen a
obtenu un nouveau prêt sachant que le
pré russe lui a été re-ochelonné
jusqu'en 2028 et que donc si Madame Le
Pen était présidente de la République
elle serait en même temps débitrice
d'une banque russe ce qui porterait
fortement atteinte à sa liberté de
manœuvre
aujourd'hui
le rassemblement national est totalement
isolé c'est grands moments où Madame Le
Pen annonce intervalles réguliers
qu'elle va monter un groupe puisque tout
le monde rêve de la rejoindre ça fait
pschit à chaque fois aujourd'hui le
groupe dans lequel vous êtes le groupe
identité et démocratie un drôle de choix
de nom parfois les mots non plus le même
sens il est en réalité le cinquième
groupe au Parlement européen citez-moi
une seule victoire que vous avez
remporté une seule de vos initiatives
une opposition minoritaire naturellement
apporte peu de combat elle se prépare et
je l'espère à remporter la victoire
acceptez-vous qu'il y ait une position
et je ne peux pas laisser passer ce que
vous avez dit sur les financements je
reprends ce que j'ai indiqué est-il
normal que dans une démocratie soit
impossible à cause de cette argument
pour parler des des contrôles aux
frontières les frontières de l'Europe
les moyens des contrôler tanière à chaux
c'est un peu de pédagogie l'espace
Schengen c'est quoi aujourd'hui comment
comment le réformer parce que les deux
les deux finalistes sont sur cette
question effectivement dans les deux cas
il y a des propositions de réformer cet
espace Schengen donc c'est un espace
dans lequel il est prévu qu'il n'y ait
pas de contrôle quand on circule à
l'intérieur et qui s'accompagne du coup
d'un renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières extérieures c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui tout le monde ne fait pas
partie du club Schengen parce que on
estime que certains États sont pas assez
fort solide pour assumer les frontières
extérieures donc pour du côté de
Emmanuel Macron il est question de de
d'instaurer un comité de pilotage
Schengen en fait pour pouvoir suivre un
petit peu ce qui s'y passe parce que et
du côté de Marine Le Pen c'est retrouver
la maîtrise des frontières qui qui est
l'intérêt a priori pourquoi c'est débats
sur la réforme parce que dans le code
Schengen il est prévu actuellement qu'il
est possible de réintroduire
temporairement des contrôles assez
frontières intérieures temporairement
normalement alors avec une notification
à la Commission pour une période de six
mois mais ce temporaire en France il
dure depuis 2015 et c'est d'ailleurs on
est le seul pays à le faire sur toutes
nos frontières depuis 2015 et donc
forcément ça interroge mais finalement
ça interroge surtout du côté français
sur l'espace Schengen voilà si je peux
peut-être continuer sur le la question
de l'asile aussi qui a un point commun
il y a une question commune qui a assez
intéressante sur l'expulsion des
personnes en situation irrégulière pour
Emmanuel Macron il y a une volonté de
réformer le droit d'asile qui serait a
priori en cours pour permettre en fait
une fois que les demandeurs sont rejetés
de pouvoir les expulser directement
enfin que la même le même juge puisse le
faire et du côté évidemment de Marine Le
Pen c'est une question plutôt de la
Convention européenne droit de l'homme
de pouvoir s'en passer pour expulser
toutes les personnes voilà et sur cette
aspect il y a aussi une forme de points
communs sur la tient la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et juin
la France compte-t-elle la respecter si
Marine Le Pen est éluge avait cru
comprendre qu'il y avait certains
articles dont elle voulait se
débarrasser oui le premier des droits de
l'homme c'est le droit des Français à
décider qui peut rentrer sur leur
territoire et a décidé qu'elle se quels
sont les conditions d'accès à la
citoyenneté le projet de Marine Le Pen
est assez précis dans ce domaine c'est
que tout candidat a l'accès au
territoire pour des raisons diverses et
notamment politiques devra poser sa
demande dans le pays d'origine ou d'un
pays extérieur et s'il est admis il
gagnera le territoire français si
quelqu'un entre illégalement sur le
territoire français il n'aura pas de
chance d'avoir accès ou de pouvoir
rester sur ce territoire
je pense que nous partageons un point
commun c'est le souhait de tenir les
frontières extérieures de l'Europe vous
l'avez dit à juste titre un pays comme
la Bulgarie par exemple ne fait pas
partie de Schengen parce qu'on estime
qu'il n'a pas une maîtrise suffisante de
ses frontières des pays comme la Suisse
font partie de l'espace Schengen elle
parce que ils ont maîtrise etc etc ce
sont des points que je pense nous
partageons le point sans doute que nous
ne partageons pas c'est que nous
souhaitons en effet rendre aux Français
la maîtrise du droit d'accès à leur
territoire et du droit d'accès à la
citoyenneté je ne pense pas que ce soit
dans vos propositions et c'est en effet
une différence majeure entre nous parce
que c'est une différence au fond sur la
souveraineté et sur la légitimité
la différence majeure c'est le réalisme
contre le fait de vendre du vent bien
sûr que n'importe quel pays n'importe
quel peuple veut pouvoir décider qui
entre sur son territoire je relève tout
de même que le droit d'asile ne fait pas
la demande d'asile ne fait pas de vous
un migrant illégal
il est parfaitement légitime et les gars
lorsque vous fuyez une guerre ou une
persécution d'entrer dans un territoire
et de demander l'asile ce qui est
nécessaire et ce que d'ailleurs nous
avons fait c'est de raccourcir le délai
d'examen de cette demande d'asile parce
que un délai trop long c'est mauvais
pour le demandeur d'asile c'est mauvais
pour tout le monde et là-dessus nous
avons travaillé il faut continuer à le
faire encore davantage mais là ou Madame
Le Pen vend du vent c'est que vous
pouvez faire toutes les plus belles
déclarations de la terre
comment luttez-vous contre l'arrivée de
migrants illégaux vous décrétez vous
fixez des quotas vous dites cela je n'en
veux pas les migrants et Lego ceux qui
n'ont pas déposé de demande d'asile
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup en France
aussi qui est partout en Europe qui
entre sur le territoire et qui essayent
de passer entre les gouttes qu'est-ce
que Madame Le Pen va faire que nous ne
faisons pas déjà
pourquoi est-ce que Madame Le Pen est
mal à l'aise avec la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme en quoi
le respect des droits de tous les êtres
humains devraient être un handicap pour
quelqu'un qui gouverne un pays comme la
France je ne vois pas à part une posture
qui n'amènerait à rien de particulier
sauf à vociférer mais derrière que
fait-on ce que nous faisons depuis des
années dialoguer avec les pays d'origine
faire en sorte de tarir à la fois les
raisons des migrations économiques de
tarir les réseaux de passeurs ça
nécessite un dialogue exigeant avec les
pays des régimes les pays de transit ça
nécessite aussi pour ce dont nous avons
besoin parce que nous avons besoin nous
avons des emplois qui ne sont pas pourvu
en France
on a bien compris pour répondre d'une
phrase alors allez-y intégrer je me
doutais bien que vous lui réponds je
voudrais parler quand même de la course
de la contribution
je citerai simplement quelqu'un qui
n'est pas au rassemblement national qui
est Jean-Pierre Chevènement dans
Jean-Pierre Chevènement dans sa
fondation respublica a écrit en fait la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
les dispositions appliquées sont en
train de consacrer un droit illimité à
tout migrants de rester pour une période
indéfinie dans le pays dans le
territoire qu'il a gagné c'est à peu
près le cas combien d'expulsions par an
en France non mais il y a quand même un
critère c'est le risque de dortcio de
traitement et de toute façon dans la
procédure d'asile aussi il y a des
personnes qui ne pourront pas être
expulsés par la suite donc ça n'est pas
que la Cour européenne droit de l'homme
qui l'empêche nous ne vivons pas là les
réfugiés effectivement menacés comme
c'est le cas actuellement pour le drame
ukrainien par la guerre par des mauvais
traitements etc nous visons les réfugiés
économiques
avec la bénédiction du rassemblement
national
un dernier élément est-ce qu'on a le
temps combien de temps me reste-t-il
chers
Marine Le Pen qui parle de la
contribution de la France à l'Union et
puis je te donnerai la parole en
conclusion en écoute je ne souhaite pas
arrêter de verser la contribution de la
France à l'Union européenne je souhaite
la baisser
voilà je souhaite la faire revenir au
niveau qui était la sienne
sous Jacques Chirac c'est à dire en
réalité au niveau de la contribution
nette à l'Union européenne
et pour cela je souhaite la baisser de 5
milliards alors qu'elle est aujourd'hui
entre 8 et 9
milliards en moyenne voilà donc c'est
c'est tout simple
allez juin quand je vais au restaurant
avec des amis j'aime bien que tout le
monde paie sa part qu'est-ce qui va se
passer si la France paye plus l'addition
au même au même niveau que les autres on
peut rediscuter sur on peut rediscuter
avant au moment de commander sur les
plaques on choisit c'est très exactement
ce que demande Marine Le Pen Marine Le
Pen dit que sur un certain nombre de
sujets bien entendu la France va
continuer à participer et à payer ce
qu'elle doit l'Europe et puis nous
pensons simplement que sur un certain
nombre de sujets on peut diminuer notre
contribution ou l'enlever nous sommes
par ailleurs assez opposés au principe
des ressources propres que l'Union veut
acquérir allez on termine là-dessus
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat merci Tania je rappelle que
les surligneurs sont nos partenaires
dans ce dans cette élection
présidentielle